Es gibt neue erkenntnisse zu der in der kür. Am ide entdeckten verborgenen kammer wir hatten ja anfang november 2017 darüber berichtet jetzt haben experten
ideen entwickelt was sich in dem bisher geheim
Hohlraum verbergen könnte was es ist und wann wir es wie zu sehen bekommt jetzt den krieg zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ich habe zuerst mal vielen dank an alle die meine aussprache kritisiert haben ab jetzt mache ich es richtig
Chaos pyramide es ist eine absolute sensation in der krebstherapie wurde ein neuer riesiger geheimer
Hohlraum entdeckt und das mit teilchenphysik zitat das ist definitiv die entdeckung des jahrhunderts es gab viele
Hypothesen über die pyramide aber niemand konnte sich vorstellen
Das ist über der großen galerie so einen großen raum gibt so der archäologe und
Ägyptologe yukinori kavai, im magazin national geographic und das sensationelle ist auch wie der hohlraum entdeckt wurde mit
Teilchenphysik wurde dieses neue wirklich große geheimnis in der kür. Am ide entdeckt und es ist wirklich riesig eine kammer
30 meter lang und acht meter hoch und breit oberhalb der galerie des ganges der zur königs kammer für die teilchenphysik
Machte die entdeckung möglich millionen haben die kann man nachgewiesen sie entstehen wenn
Protonen aus dem weltall auf unsere atmosphäre treffen dabei zerfallen atomkerne und es entstehen die simeon sie sind wie elektro
negativ geladenen zerfallen aber bereits nach
2,2 milliarden von außen betrachtet existieren sie aber viel länger die relativitätstheorie macht es möglich sie bewegen sich fast mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
Fort deshalb wirkt die zeit der station auf sie und sie haben für uns rund zehn
mal mehr zeit bis sie zerfallen in dieser zeit können sie die erdoberfläche
Erreichen auf dem weg durch materie werden sie dann abgelenkt fliegen sie nicht durch materie werden sie nicht abgelenkt stellt man in einer pyramide
also unterhalb eines hohlraums
Detektoren auf treffen dort mehr millionen auf als unter einer dicken stein schicht wie mit einem röntgengerät können jetzt auf diese weise
Hohlräume entdeckt werden und genau das ist jetzt passiert oberhalb der galerie muss es nach den messungen der
teilchenphysiker und physikerin einen hohlraum geben 30 meter lang und eben acht meter aber was verbirgt sich in dieser kammer wobei die
ägyptologie lieber erst mal von einem
hohlraum spricht denn was darin enthalten sein könnte
Das ist erstmal reine vermutung nur eines ist bisher gewiss zitat aktuell wissen wir nicht ob der
Horizontal oder geneigt ist ob er aus einer
konstruktion oder aus mehreren aufeinanderfolgenden
Konstruktionen bestehen wir wissen dass der hohlraum dort existiert das er beeindruckend ist und dass er von keiner theorie
vorhergesagt wurde das sagt der koautor der millionen studie mehdi karrubi
Doch es gibt hinweise darauf warum es diesen hohlraum geben könnte kate spence
Archäologen der university cambridge vermutet dass der hohlraum zum bau der pyramide genutzt wurde eine innen rampe auf ihr hätte man die
besonders großen steinblöcke für das dach der kammern transportiert die lage
Des hohlraums würde für diese these spricht die ägyptologin salima ikram von amerikanischen universität in kairo
Ist auch der ansicht dass der hohlraum während des baus genutzt wurde da er aber über der galerie liege meint sie
Dass, er eher beim bau der galerie genutzt wurde trotzdem bleibt sie sehr vorsichtig zitat
Ich glaube es ist nie zu früh um zu spekulieren aber man kann ziemlich daneben liegen ja jetzt will das
forschungsteam einen blick in den hohlraum werfen aber ganz vorsichtig nicht soll beschädigt werden und
Keine löcher sollen gebohrt werden zitat da gibt es eine menge
Schweres dickes gestein und wenn man da rein dort weiß man nicht wie sich das auf das gesamte bauwerk
auswirken würde das
Sagt ikram es wird also vielleicht noch etwas dauern bis wir einen ersten blick in den hohlraum werfen können und vielleicht werden wir alle von
den geheimnissen hinter den dicken mauern überrascht ich bin auf jeden fall gespannt wie ein flitzebogen
Wenn es neuester so gibt dann erfahre es natürlich hier wenn er kein video dazu und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt
Mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann verpasst er kein video hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Mysteriöses rätsel um nasca linien endlich gelüftet und ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt kann